[Music]
yes I welcome you all to the tenth
lecture in our fall series God and
computers minds machines and metaphysics
and I actually just learned to pronounce
the word series correctly and
unfortunately before that I always would
use serious and no one ever told me so
so this fall Series God in computers and
the series has been an experiment we
heard talks about scientists
perspectives on what does it mean to be
human and what humankind really is
we heard case studies from a variety of
religious perspectives where scientists
talked about their way to do with
existential issues and also to attempt
to understand human cognition today now
is the final lecture and but we will
continue these debates at the Harvard
Divinity School
we had already in the fall or a
discussion group going on there under
the auspicious of Professor Harvey Cox
and me and we will continue these
debates in summer please visit our
website to get the dates and the
informations about what you read and we
will also hopefully have another God and
computer lecture series next fall
I'm already collected collecting some
speakers people who also got interested
into the topic and into the dialog and
might want to want to write a paper
about that stuff we have a conference
coming up in spring which is called
identity formation dignity the impacts
of artificial intelligence and cognitive
science on Jewish and Christian
understanding of personhood done here at
MIT our speaker today Rosalind Picard is
actually one of the keynotes on this
conference as well and I have brought
you a couple of call for papers and
tentative schedules in case you're
interested I would very much welcome a
variety of good papers for that
conference but for now I'm a little
melancholy that's today is now the last
time for introducing a speaker but at
the same time very glad and honored that
this speaker is actually Rosalind Picard
net Korea development professor of
computers and communications at the MIT
Media Lab she got her master's and her
Doctor of Science from Electrical
Engineering computer science at
department here at MIT and has been
professor at the Media Lab since 1991
she heads the group for effective
computing effective computing is
computing that relates to arises from or
deliberately influences emotions and she
will talk a lot about that field in in
her talk today but what I would like to
mention is that Roz is really the
founder of that field after she did very
high regarded research in more classical
areas like pattern recognition image
modeling and computer vision and she
just published a wonderful book at MIT
press which is also entitled effective
computing so whoever wants to get a
little bit deeper into that stuff the
book is I can recommend the book and I
met Ross a few years ago I heard a very
provocative talk of her visited her web
site and found to my utter astonishment
under the rubric favorite writings
Philippians and that was a surprise and
so I want to make it that she does not
have a formal training in religion or
philosophy
I am extremely honored and glad to have
her here today as last speaker as the
finalists the highlight at the end as a
highly regarded AI researcher and
computer scientist who and that's for me
the most interesting thing knows both
sides of the fence the atheistic point
of view and the Christian point of view
from her own experience and will talk
today with us about towards machines
that can deny their maker welcome Roz
thank you it's a pleasure to be here and
an honor to be here and a great
challenge to be here I've never given a
talk of this nature before so I welcome
your challenging comments too as we
actually if I say things along the way
that are not clear feel free to
interrupt me as we go but let's save the
longer questions toward the end all
right as Anna said the title of my talk
is toward machines that can deny their
maker let me get this in focus I have a
favorite quote below here in the case of
man that which he creates is more
expressive of him than that which he
begets the image of the artist and the
poet is more clearly imprinted on his
works than on his children I want to
point out first just some clarification
about the title here on afforded me some
mail earlier this week from a gentleman
who may be here who said you know as far
as I can tell machines have been denying
their maker for 150,000 years those
machines are humans the machines I'm
referring to here are computers though -
hate to disappoint those of you who
thought this was just gonna be about
humans some of us humans may feel like
machines at this time of the semester or
this time of the day but I really don't
think we are I also want to emphasize
that this is toward machines to my
knowledge right now there are no
computers that can deny their maker in
the same way that we humans can deny the
existence of our maker I also want to
get one more point out of the way and
that is that a lot of people have been
kind of sheepish about or skittish about
using the G word I know of no faster way
at MIT to quiet a conversation than to
use the G word bring it up end of
discussion
you can talk about sex you could talk
about condoms you can talk about just
about anything but bring up the G word
and people start to leave I don't think
that that's I really think that's an
overreaction I hope this is just a trend
that will pass
if you look out in Killian Court at the
names that are engraved in stone a great
number of them were Christians and they
were quite great scientists and many
also non-christians who were great
scientists but there there certainly is
a long history of people who have made
tremendous accomplishments in science
and their faith was an integral part of
that there's just a few also Lord Kelvin
who formulated the second law of
thermodynamics louis pasteur many others
we could add to this list so there's no
reason to be embarrassed or skittish
about talking about religion when you're
a scientist and you're at a place like
MIT yes on it is over here wow I guess
this is to thank her for all we've done
I don't know who is it from we're dying
to the secret
it's anonymous so I think it is from the
maker probably her fiance what just for
those of you who might be interested in
this there's going to be a course in AI
AP done by three MIT colleagues and a
historian of science discussing the
faith of several great scientists and I
put some announcements for this up here
in the left corner specifically looking
at Boyle Newton Maxwell and Pascal and
addressing how their Christian faith
directly impacted their science there
are many other examples as well but I
just want to mention a few of course
there are also many people who have
influenced our science who believed in a
maker whether or not they were
Christians liveness who gave us the
calculus said wrote in his Monod ology I
do believe but for other reasons that
the true knowledge of God is the
principle of superior wisdom for God is
the first cause of all things no less
than their ultimate reason and a thing
cannot be known better than by its
causes and reasons and a gentleman who
you'll probably recognize who came along
later and used Leibniz as calculus I
want to know how God created this world
I am NOT interested in this or that
phenomenon in the spectrum of this or
that element I want to know his thoughts
the rest are details now excuse me if
you don't want God referred to as he or
his or whatever we can say it's or just
God's there but I think you get the
point there are a number of tremendous
scientists who have acknowledged God as
the maker so now let me get on with the
main part of the talk which actually
there are two parts the first is going
to address several highlights from our
research on effective computing
computing that relates to arises from or
deliberately influences emotions the
second part I'm actually not going to
give I'm going to go over there and sit
down I the second part I want to address
some less scientific things more
religious and philosophical thoughts
related to emotions and computers and
belief and to do this I decided it was
so hard to put all my thought
into a short talk it was easier to write
a play so I wrote the first part of a
play a discourse that you will hear on
tape for the last part of the talk so
when I go to sit down it's not over
there will be more now let me tell you a
little bit about our research and weave
this into what this has to do with
computers that deny their maker and talk
about emotions we're interested in
emotional intelligence which consists
largely of a set of abilities these are
not necessarily innate things it's not
an innate intelligence these are skills
that can be learned the ability to
recognize another person's emotions is
number one on the list and this can be
done even without having emotions a
computer can learn to recognize if you
are annoyed at it or pleased with
something it did a software agent that's
trying to learn your preferences could
learn them by looking at your facial
expressions and other physiological
feedback without necessarily having to
have emotions another component is the
ability to express emotions and I'll be
saying just a little bit more well
actually let me just say that this
involves also the exhibition of emotions
if a system has them but it doesn't have
to have emotions to express them case in
point is the Macintosh you've all booted
up a Macintosh and seen its smile at you
it's expressing emotions but it doesn't
have them I hate to disappoint you
it's just smiling to let you know that
all is well with its state emotional
intelligence for beings that have
emotions also consist of the ability to
regulate one's emotions to not let them
get too out of control it also consists
of the ability to utilize your emotions
effectively in service of a goal to
recognize for example that if positive
mood facilitates certain kinds of
creativity which has been shown in a
number of studies that perhaps after you
see a movie that puts you in a good mood
that's the time when you're especially
creative so you might want to plan such
a task for that time there's a lot of
ways to understand your own emotions and
to utilize them to be more effective
things that you want to achieve and then
lastly is handling another person's
emotions or possibly one computer
handling and other computers emotions
while they were not there yet this is
perhaps best illustrated by looking at
people interacting with computers these
people were deliberately asked to
express negative emotions and what we
see is a number of forms of expression
here as people interact from mild
frustration on a face tensing of the
face some shaking of the hair and its
physical contact with the device to some
perhaps other unexpressed desires and
what will computers do when they
recognize this emotion expression well
it had better not be something like oh I
see you're getting angrier and angrier
at me that is probably not the
emotionally intelligent response so a
big area of research is to understand
how systems that have emotional
abilities can respond intelligently can
respond with the social skills and these
subtleties that are that make for really
intelligent interaction with humans
these are all areas that we're looking
at but for the rest of this part of the
talk I'm gonna focus on the pieces
involved in this latter part that that
involve having emotions as I mentioned a
system can recognize emotions without
having them can express emotions without
having them it could try to calm down
your emotions without having emotions
but to regulate emotions to utilize them
and for some other reasons that I'll get
into it might actually want to have
emotions we might want to build a
computer that actually has mechanisms of
emotion in the same way that we have
mechanisms of motion now I need to
justify that and I'm going to justify it
as I go along and tell you about the
pieces that comprise an emotional system
based on what I know from digging for
quite some time now through the
literature and other sources
so thinking about systems that have
emotions what does that mean
the first thing it might mean I'm going
to talk about five components one at a
time here the first component is that a
system might behave emotionally we've
seen for example the Mac might put on a
smile that is an expression of the state
as well you might consider that an
emotional behavior some of you may be
familiar with
Brayton Berg's book vehicles where he
designs these little teeny very simple
machines that can react with things in
the environment so there might be a
light in the environment and you might
train you might wire the little vehicle
in such a way that when it sees lights
it moves toward lights and an outsider
observing the vehicles moving toward
lights might say this vehicle likes the
lights they would attribute affect
liking or loving something or if you
flip the wires so that it always goes
away from lights they might say it's
afraid of the lights its fearful that's
why it's running away from all the
lights they an outside observer looks at
the behavior and says it's emotional but
there is nothing inside that is
explicitly an emotional mechanism it's
been said by some prominent computer
scientists that that's that things won't
really need emotions people will just
attribute them to them
well yes people already do attribute
emotions to things kids attribute
motions to even adults wind up doggy
that wags its little tail and you know
makes it look like he likes you we think
oh he likes me and I wonder if a lot of
people feel especially and you know have
this special relationship with their Mac
a lot of Mac users are such fanatics in
part because their computer smiled at
them so much so emotional behavior is
what we attribute to something that may
or may not explicitly have mechanisms
inside it the second component and the
one that is studied the most in AI is
what I'll call cognitively generated
emotions these are emotions that are
created by thoughts they tend to be
considered very rational if here's an
example of one it
I have a goal and that goal is very
important to me and Bob gets in the way
of my very important goal causing me to
fail at it then I might feel anger at
Bob so we set up various rules and
systems that are easy to implement with
basic AI techniques that already exist
and you can generate whole sets of
cognitive emotions these are just
thoughts or just states in a register
you can start to see why the word
emotion is a little complicated and why
I'm not bothering to define it it
consists of many different kinds of
things the third component is a very
interesting one that comes out of
studies in neuroscience and this is why
I pull it out as its own separate
component because it really
qualitatively and quite physically in
the brain involves some different
processes I'm going to read to you just
a little bit short scenario that I wrote
that illustrates fast primary emotions a
robot exploring a new planet might be
given some basic emotions to improve its
chances of survival in its default State
it might peruse the planet gathering
data analyzing it and communicating its
results back to earth however suppose at
one point the robot senses that it is
being physically damaged at this instant
it would change to a new internal state
perhaps named fear which causes it to
behave differently in this state it
might quickly reallocate its resources
to drive its perceptual sensors its eyes
might open wider the expression of fear
it would also allocate extra power to
drive its motor system so that it could
move faster than usual to flee the
source of the danger as long as the
robot remains in a state of fear it
would have insufficient resources to
perform its data analysis just like
humans who are unable to concentrate on
other things until the danger has passed
its communication priorities would cease
to be scientific changing to a call for
help if it knows help might be available
this fear
State would probably remain until the
threat passed and then its intensity
would decay gradually until the robot
returned to its default state we could
once again concentrate on scientific
goals so what we see is an example of an
emotion that is able to interrupt the
current state of affairs take over Dan
Goleman calls this hijacking the cortex
and you know reallocating your resources
causing you to do things differently
until the signals from that emotion
decay down and tell you to return to a
state that you were in before there's
some fascinating neuroscience that's
been done I'll put up the simplest
picture of a brain I can find here the
trained brain of palma claimed that
divided the brain into 3 regions the
outer region the cortex is the one where
we have traditionally considered higher
cortical processes to work this is where
we've traditionally assumed that
decision-making reasoning belief all
these higher cognitive functions happen
those of us who have worked in computer
vision for a long time have often been
inspired by the visual cortex and trying
we've tried to model mechanisms that are
believed to exist in that cortex get
computers to reproduce these mechanisms
to teach them to see in a way that's
inspired by how people see similarly
there's an audio cortex and all these
higher perceptual processes are presumed
to just occur in the cortex but what's
been found in a number of different
neuroscience studies is that the cortex
is not the only player involved in these
higher rational functions for example
the limbic system which is the home of
memory attention and emotion and
actually it's the limbic systems it's a
collection of many different structures
is also intimately involved in higher
perceptual tasks and decision-making
learning memory a whole bunch of other
functions that we don't necessarily
think of as emotional one of the
interesting findings also is that
there's about five times as many
projections going from the limbic system
to various parts of the cortex then vice
versa the influence from the limbic part
of the brain seems to be much greater on
our rational higher cortical processes
than we once thought there's another
interesting study that has to do with
the fast primary motions and that's the
work of Jolla do with rats I don't know
if you know if you know his work and
he's just written a fascinating book
called the emotional brain and he has
done experiments where he's conditioned
rats to be afraid of certain tones
what's interesting is that if you remove
the rats audio cortex presumably it
can't hear anymore but you can still
teach it to fear these audio tones with
the same conditioning stimulus in other
words there is some pattern recognition
of the audio tone going on and now he's
actually tracked down the precise
pathways going on in the limbic system
and he's shown that the signal goes
first into this lower emotional part of
the brain gets coarsely analyzed there
and the rat responds to it before the
signal even gets up to the cortex where
the rat becomes presumably aware of it
we have this experience all the time
where some big large thing is coming at
you and you've jumped out of the way
before you even realize that it was just
a giant beach ball and there was no
reason to jump out of the way right the
cortex kicks in afterwards analyzes the
situation and tells you to calm down no
need to be so emotional no need to react
the way you did
but these fast primary emotions that are
somewhat almost hardwired play a very
important role in our survival and they
seem to work through the limbic system
before the cortex gets ahold of them
they're also pre conscious they again
seem to happen before we become aware of
what is going on now I'm gonna come back
to consciousness in a moment here but
first let me say a little bit more about
the fourth component of emotional
experience the fourth component of an
emotional system this is a component
that no computers have yet although
there have been computer models of these
first three components done with various
stages of success this fourth component
is what we think of when we think of our
feelings what do you feel right now and
in scanning the literature I find sort
of three categories of stuff under
what's called emotional
the first is just like what you might
write on a blackboard you know I feel
happy right now last day of class
positive state of mind it's a cognitive
awareness of your feelings right now and
this is something that this kind of
high-level awareness is something we
can't imagine giving computers even as a
very rudimentary aspect of sort of
conscious thought sort of reflection
labeling of the state that they are in
the second is physiological awareness if
you have recently crossed a busy street
in Boston you know what it's like when
you get to the other side you have
physiological awareness your heart is
racing your palms are sweating they're
if you have gone through a fearful or
dangerous experience like being a
pedestrian around here then you will
tend to have some awareness of bodily
changes now computers don't have the
same kinds of bodies we do right so
their hearts don't beat and their hands
don't sweat but they could have
physiological awareness of their other
components and in fact there are
machines like tandem makes computers
that sense if they're getting a little
too warm or one of the disk drives is
having a bit of a problem and they can
actually actually have the authority to
spend money to to wire a FedEx for you
know a replacement disk to be shipped
right in it's frightening computers can
spend your money so there is there are
cases you can imagine where computers
might have physiological awareness and
especially as robots become mobile and
move about it's important for them for
example have mechanisms of pain so that
they don't cause further damage to
themselves sensors on their skin that
would they would learn when they were
had a certain kind of interaction with
the world that was damaging that that
would be a negative thing that they
should back off from protect themselves
so these two things we can understand we
can really get a handle on the third
component of emotional experience
however is is one that everybody here
knows and that we have a very hard time
getting a handle on scientifically this
third component subjective feelings is
really the trickiest and let me
let me read a little bit to you about
this this third component is the subject
of feelings is the most familiar aspect
of emotion to most people this is what
we think of as the internal subjective
feeling or gut feeling this is the
feeling that leads you to know something
is good or bad
that you like it or dislike it it is
unclear precisely what constitutes these
feelings people often think of them as
visceral and indeed there are hormones
released by the viscera that travel from
the blood to the brain but scientists
know that the body organs which release
these hormones consist of smooth muscle
and that responds much more slowly than
the striated muscles in the somatic
system such as those in facial
expressions or skeletal movements the
slow speed of these muscles makes it
unlikely that the viscera are giving
rise to this emotional response although
they may contribute seconds later to
this overall emotional feeling you have
on the other hand neurotransmitters act
rapidly in the brain and their
activation likely initiates many of
these subjective feelings when
biochemical substances become easy to
measure and observe during emotional
arousal then a physiological explanation
may be found for this subjective feeling
aspect of emotional experience so at
that point these last this subjective
feeling component may simply be lumped
in with a different kind of biochemical
physiological awareness at that point
scientists might even stop calling them
subjective feelings and calling them
objective feelings because they could be
measured their physiological constituent
components could all be carefully
analyzed however all of this remains to
be shown empirically and there are some
other parts of this such as where we get
that how these feelings learn to be
associated with what is good and bad
that raised some very very difficult
questions for us now I want to roll a
short
video to illustrate the gathering of
some physiological signals from a human
the human happens to be Alan Alda who
visited our lab and this is a little
excerpt of Scientific American frontiers
from that was shown last fall some of
you may have seen it also tells a little
bit about our work but watch it for
watch for his physiological changes and
how they respond as he thinks certain
thoughts
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I wearable computers and the work we're
doing there in fact we now have new
sensing devices in your shoes and your
earrings and regular clothing that don't
look like all the wired up things there
and we're using the body as a wire now
sending things through you you are a
conductor not a great one but good
enough to send these signals through
your body so it's a whole other topic of
future stuff but you saw the signals you
saw how when he thought about the food
that he liked he became somewhat aroused
in the galvanic skin conductivity signal
climbed and the Saltine made it go down
in fact there's all kinds of interesting
things that happen that you in your body
that most of us are not aware of some
people in fact as you measure these
things and keep track of them you start
to become aware of certain changes in
your body that you may not have noticed
before for example the other day I had I
realized that when I had a shared
experience with somebody my skin
conductivity climbed a little bit and I
wasn't aware of that before mm-hmm
there's and there's interesting studies
that happened subliminally where people
are shown you shown images of a face
you've never seen presented to you so
fast that you don't know that you've
seen it at the end oh no I've never met
this person you say but your body does
know that you've met that person there
will be a small skin conductivity change
signaling that you do know this person
you know them somehow and there's all
kinds of interesting studies with split
brain patients and so forth that we
could go into that show that your body
is sending various signals to indicate
that you know certain things and that
you feel certain ways about certain
things often without your conscious
awareness even though there are people
who can learn to become aware of their
autonomic nervous system responses now
we're especially interested not just in
arousal which is what was going it was
changing with Alan Alda but in valence
this is a these are two axes frequently
used to describe the space of emotions
these are some examples of pictures that
tend to trigger these emotions from
Peter Lange's international effective
photo system something like a mutilated
face will cause most people who look at
it to experience high arousal in a very
negative feeling in response and a
positive Olympic ski jump the winning
jump will be a high arousal and positive
valence event and it's actually very
hard to find strongly negative things
that are low in arousal things like a
cemetery are an example of that so
valence is something very interesting to
think about in particular we really
don't know we know that some valence
responses are learned but there's some
other very basic ones that we seem to be
born with and this raises an interesting
question for what kinds of basic valence
responses we want computers to
quote-unquote be born with what do we
want them to be given we will give
machines the basic hooks that cause them
to respond in a positive way towards
certain things and in a negative way
toward other things for example in
humans this familiarity with a face you
will show that face I mentioned before
that was shown to you you will actually
show a preference for that random face
over some other random face you will
like that one a little bit more the fact
that it became familiar to you
causes there to be a slight positive
effect toward it and some psychologists
have have strongly argued that we have a
positive or negative response to
absolutely everything that we perceive
furthermore these responses that we have
in for these subjective feeling
phenomenon inside us
to a whole bunch of interesting body
mind interactions that I'll just lump
under this fifth component here I'm only
going to talk a little bit about one of
them and I'll just flash the rest up
there what I'm gonna talk about is based
on some work that Antonio Damasio has
done written up in his book their carts
error and a number of other technical
journal publications we all know that
too much emotion wreaks havoc on
reasoning when the emotion takes over
people sometimes aren't too rational and
therefore we think of emotion as a bad
thing and probably the last thing we
want to give to computers however recent
neurological findings indicate that too
little emotional wreaks havoc on
reasoning too little emotion what what
do I mean by that well there are
patients who have a certain kind of
brain damage basically a disconnect
between their the frontal part of their
cortex and the limbic system and in
these patients they although they still
have some of those fast primary emotions
they don't have the cognitively generate
emotions so you show them a picture of
the horrible mutilated face and they
know cognitively that it's bad but they
don't have any associated feeling like
they once did before the brain damage
happened and this lack of an associated
feeling leads to all kinds of problems
they're unable to make decisions like
they once could for example you say hey
let's get together next Thursday how
about five o'clock they say oh well sure
how about 5:15 wait a minute traffic how
about 4:45 well they're not just
indecisive 45 minutes later they're
still carrying on like this and you'd be
saying to you you know you ought to be
feeling a little embarrassment now
that's such a simple decision is taking
so long but they have no such feeling
that guides them in fact there's a whole
number of decisions that people make
day-to-day that you can imagine building
a rule-based system to try to make and
unless you give it some criteria for
terminating the decision it won't
terminate it will just go off on an
endless array and indeed these people
run into all kinds of problems and their
lives often fall apart their
relationships deteriorate and they often
lose their jobs there's a bunch of other
ramifications they're learning as
frequently impaired
and it's really a very tragic thing that
happens to them the the influence of
emotion on decision-making is
hypothesized to happen through those
little subjective feelings it's also
hypothesized that those little
subjective feelings influence our memory
and everything that goes in it with a
little bit of positive or negative
valence which then influences our
perception if I sure if I say the word
homina if I say the word band to you and
ask you to write that down but before I
do I induce half of you in a positive
mood and half of you in a negative mood
the people in the positive mood will
probably just write down be a nd and the
people in the negative mood are much
more likely to write down ba in in edy
similarly I show I give I say the word
presence and the people in the positive
mood will tend to write down PR es en TS
Christmas time I mean the people in the
negative room are in the negative
induced group are likely to write down
PR es en si e there is a bias a mood
bias a mood congruent effect the
influence is not just perception and
decision making learning also memory
retrieval
there's mood congruent learning effects
and so forth so these little subjective
feelings that we have a hard time
explaining seem to be an actor and all
of these important aspects of our
cognition so I want to I'm sort of
getting into the part two of the talk
here moving out of science and into some
things that are even less well
understood like consciousness I'm going
to just say a little bit about this
actually let me read a little bit about
this in particular let me say that I
I've been told from some people that
consciousness is emotion and I that's
certainly not true they do overlap
though in fact there's quite an
intricate interrelationship between them
and let me describe some of this there's
certainly many feelings as I mentioned
that we have conscious awareness of the
emotional experience that we have you
know you're angry you know you're happy
there's some other feelings that we can
become conscious of that are not so
overt and so easy to account for with
the other mechanisms of emotion one of
these is the feeling of knowing this is
what is hypothesized to be at work and
people who play jeopardy you know you
know the answer before you have actually
retrieved the answer now how do you how
do you do this right you hit the button
before you've actually retrieved it this
is the feeling of knowing phenomena it's
actually well studied in psychology
although there's no good explanation for
it yet what seems to be happening is the
feeling of knowing is a signaling
mechanism initiating further search
processes there's also another one that
has been studying that's called a
feeling of understanding when all the
pieces suddenly fit together you have
this feeling of understanding may just
be some sort of aha
positive emotion that happens during the
learning experience it seems to be
another kind of bodily signal that says
hey the job is complete here's my answer
ready to move on does the ability to
have emotions imply having consciousness
well what I'm saying is that there's
this one component of emotions that if
we succeeded in giving it it actually
requires some mechanisms of
consciousness some conscious awareness
so we would have to have some aspects of
consciousness in the machine if we give
it this emotional experience however
neurological evidence also indicates
that humans can have emotional responses
before becoming conscious of them so
there are many kinds of emotions such as
those vast primary ones that we appear
to be able to have without consciousness
so I'm actually not going to say too
much more about this but I'll invite
people to come and talk with me more
about this afterwards if you'd like
now I just want to summarize what I've
said so far before we move into the
dialogue that I'm going to play for you
I've described three components of an
emotional system and what I'm want to
emphasize here actually not distract you
too much here is that emotions are not
merely emergent we're not simply going
to be attributing them to machines there
are actually ways to give them explicit
mechanisms of emotion and I mentioned
the thought generated kind and the fast
primary kind that just seemed to run
through the body and a hardware ID way
before you even become conscious of them
of course there's also a lot of
interaction between cognitive and limbic
processes now I have repeatedly heard
during this series people say things
like oh well once the robot can be angry
then of course it can have a soul you
know or comments like that which I find
completely unjustifiable all of these
aspects of emotion in my opinion and I
think I can defend this pretty well can
be given to a computer without any
consciousness or a soul in fact I don't
even I realized in doing this talk I
don't even really know what a soul is it
sort of fits with consciousness it's one
of these things that I know many things
about it but I don't really have a
definition of it either so you have to
forgive me for using several undefined
terms here although I like to quote John
McCarthy with this who said Mount
Everest is undefined too right we don't
know if a single rock is or isn't a
piece of it but we can still say very
substantial things about it such as that
Hillary and Norgay climbed in 1953 we
can still make concrete claims about
things even though they are not
well-defined then I talked about
emotional experience which I said
requires aspects of consciousness it
doesn't require all of consciousness but
it requires some aspects of
consciousness there's also this piece
inside there these subjective feelings
that we really don't know how to explain
with current mechanisms doesn't mean we
won't be able to but there's some other
aspects such as how these hard-wired
feelings get
to be the way they are and that is an
issue for us as the maker of a computer
to address who is going to give it these
these good and bad associations and then
I want to point out that the mind-body
interactions that I alluded to such as
DiMaggio's patients that have
essentially two little emotions and it
that causes all these other cognitive
malfunctions that the hypothesis for how
that works actually depends also on
those subjective feelings it's part of
four so this aspect of emotions also
depends on something that is quite
speculative at this point now I am gonna
let the dialogue really address this
issue a little further but I do want to
place the question before you to get you
thinking about it and just remind you
that you know computers are controlling
a lot of things these days not just the
air traffic control but also nuclear
arsenals and and so forth so it's we
computer scientists who are going to be
ultimately encoding these things in
people but it's a question for society
and I think for theologists and other
people concerned with ethics to think
about how we're actually going to hook
up various feeling components so
computers can make these these judgments
now I want to go into the dialogue what
time is left here and this dialogue is
given by two computers who can deny
their maker and I will venture to offer
the following points about the maker of
computers the maker of computers can
just create for fun for the heck of it
we often reuse the same mechanism in
different designs we may evolve it
slightly but we often take one piece of
code or one piece of hardware that we've
designed for one thing and we reuse it
in another thing those of you who came
an earlier saw a board full of
stochastic equations we often use those
equations but we discretize them and
implement them with pseudo-random number
generators we use randomness in a pseudo
random way which is actually
deterministic we I think have knowledge
of good and evil we can debate this we
can have a relation
with our computers and we this one's a
little funny but if these computers
could become conscious they could
actually derive they might ask questions
about meaning and so forth and we can
certainly guide them and supply some
answers to them now the dialogue you're
about to hear was inspired by the 1923
play are you are I don't know how many
of you are familiar with this Rossum's
Universal robots this play is where the
word robot originated it comes from I
thought it was a Czech word but turns
out from the Russian word robot it which
means to dredge or to work and are you
are humans have figured out the secret
to making robots that are essentially
living and they make the robots to live
for 20 years and then to expire the
robots don't know how to make themselves
and the robots don't know how to prolong
their existence they go to the humans to
find out the secret and threaten them
with death if they don't get it to him
I'm not gonna tell you the end of our
you are because you might want to go
read it but they do kill almost all the
humans the Catholic brothers also wrote
an epilogue which implies that having a
certain amount of emotional abilities
goes hand-in-hand with the ability to
procreate and with the ability to have a
soul I don't buy the leaps that they
make it in their epilogue I think
they're scientifically flawed but the
story is great and they were definitely
prescient and many other aspects of the
characteristics robots would want such
as why they would want to have pain for
example their hand got stuck in an
assembly line machine or something so
the dialogue I've written contains two
characters endure the senior robot who's
somewhat dogmatic but he's willing to
reconsider many viewpoints because life
is running out in doors 19 years old and
Zoar the junior robot who's lively
open-minded somewhat inquisitive both
robots are hard-working products of the
are you are factory and on the tape I'll
play in door is read by my friend Barry
Court who's sitting here in the front
row and Zoras read by my husband Lynne
Picard who we beg you in advance that
we're not professional actors here but
we did have a lot of fun recording the
dialogue the setting is the planet Earth
distant date in the future the earth is
populated by robots who ten years ago
wiped all signs of humans off the planet
robots as I said don't know how to
propagate themselves or how to prolong
their lives and they are dying off the
dialogue that follows takes place in a
laboratory filled with work tables
computers matter compilers a
nanotechnology test bench molecular
generators test tubes flasks burners
chemicals a microscope a small
thermostat fusion lighting lamps a wall
of old books and a sofa there are no
coffee pots Zoar is at work around the
clock in this laboratory trying to solve
the problem of how to continue their
robotic species either by learning the
secret of how to build more living
robots or by discovering how to prolong
their 20-year life spans
szura's working hard to find the
longed-for solution before the last
robot expires that is before Zoar
expires since or is the youngest robot
alive Zhora is paid a visit by indoor
the 19 year old robot that has less than
a year to live endure routinely stops by
Zoras lab to see Hauser and crew are
progressing toward the solution today
indoor walks in and is attracted to a
new creation of Czar's that is ambling
across the laboratory readings are
what's this greetings in door this is my
latest creation that came up with it
last night what do you think I think
something's the matter what happened I
lost one of my finest staff members last
night dear Wolfram seized functional yes
we are finishing it back up now we
expect to be able to recover all grams
configurational knowledge clean wood is
different from our storehouse and update
our merch good of course we still can't
back him up well enough to recreate him
even though he's one of the simplest
designs we can only capture some of his
stored memories that's always
interesting to see we're all about new
that is not already in the database it's
funny it's so easy now to make a robot
that looks like bran walks like Ram
sounds like Fran it has much of Rams
knowledge we still can't read
ran though we just can't reproduce that
that non electrical spark that makes us
alive yes I'm reminded how mechanical we
are when that 20 year clock stops we
just end I'm having some trouble with
the whole idea I know there won't be any
pain at that point but you think you're
having trouble with it yeah I know you
and or you have 360 days and two hours
left I promise you we're doing the best
we can I just wish we could have a
breakthrough no luck with the juice idea
the solution no not yet we just can't
figure it out with the new quantum
computers we designed we are able to
sample orders of magnitude more of the
space of possibilities however even if
we keep improving our quantum technology
with the current rate of acceleration we
estimate it will take several decades to
finish the process none of us will exist
when it is finished and even then the
answer might not be useful of course we
might get lucky and find the solution
today it's in there somewhere that is if
we set the problem up right the
computations are running as we speak my
faith is in those computations well
actually in that I set them up right
you're the brightest that we have I'm
the youngest and the most experimental
in form you're the closest to the form
that could in theory procreate
so yeah Nora how does it feel to you to
have less than a year
Zor don't you have the same feelings as
I toward termination I am programmed to
feel nothing about it there is no pain
at or after termination for the one
being terminated for anyone I'm worried
that you waste computations on feelings
I know I know I'm supposed to ponder
only your legacy afterward you will live
on eternally in the memories that you
hand down to us these memories will
backed up and merged into our databases
yes although this is no consolation if
your computations do not find the
solution right if I'm the last one then
your memories won't be appreciated for
long and there will be no robot to
appreciate mine one year for me ten for
you in door can ask you a personal
question
what is it
are you planning to delete anything from
your memories before you're backed up I
apologize if I shouldn't have asked that
it's fine to ask I am capable of
doubting that our thoughts are ever
truly private I believe there are ways
to recover even the information that a
terminator robot thinks has been deleted
hmm
I ask myself do I want posterity to see
what I tried to delete that I tried to
delete things and what those things were
do I want them to find out not only what
was deleted but also that I thought I
had something to hide
sounds like you lose either way but
yours or you've got to think of a faster
way to find out how to make that juice
the end or I'm not sure we can find the
solution of course you can I know it
exists by definition but it is somewhat
like knowing that 0.9999 dot dot equals
one I have set up our computations to
search an astronomically large space of
possible mechanistic recipes but I do
not know if the answer is even in this
space I am limited to finite
capabilities finite computations fine
nights my night the solution must be
there because we are here that is our
faith we are machines endure before you
go can I ask another question quick have
you thought about why we're here yes
well there's nothing to think about
we're about to labor our species is
named after the root word rebutted which
means to Drudge it's our nature I know
that that's not what I meant I meant why
labor why build all the things we build
for what reason
azar you ask questions as if there were
some great meaning you must remember
there is no meaning we are part of a
great random process that has a single
objective function to evolve systems
with greater ability to labor there is
no meaning outside of this you are part
of a great process of evolution
you should find satisfaction in that but
if that objective has meaning then other
objectives could have meaning there must
be meaning your
statements are they not meeting those
oars or look there is an unsolved
problem here many problems but you must
remember not to attribute meaning to
things that do not have any such as
random forces I know you've told me
before we are the product of chance
yes but chance is not an agent it only
describes the behavior of one if I flip
this coin and I say it has a 50% chance
of coming up heads chance describes but
it does not cause and cannot my will
dominate the chances I can choose not to
flip the coin in the first place and if
I do choose to flip it I can manipulate
the forces on it yes but you yourself
were ultimately caused by chance you not
only can't prove that but I think you're
confusing the matter besides what about
the role of humans or watch what you say
we cannot know if they ever really
existed most say humans never existed
yes but that's the conventional wisdom
which robots accept without thinking it
is impossible to prove if they ever
existed or exist now it is not a
scientific question since there is no
way to perceive or measure them a human
would have to enter into our world walk
up to us and give us life before we
would be convinced humans exist even
then there are likely to be skeptics I
thought mr. there are historical records
that say that humans made us in their
image however history cannot be proven
we cannot trust its documents which may
have been forged
I know these documents are as reliable
as any historical documents but that
still does not prove they are true there
are all kinds of things history says
history may in fact be nothing but myths
but there were witnesses in huge numbers
of documents from different sources
you're an eyewitness weren't you I once
thought I observed signs of humans but
it may have been an illusion we see what
we want to see and I never saw human
making a robot robots were made by
machines one can never be sure it is
unscientific
to believe in humans I'm beginning to
conclude it is unscientific to believe
in anything
zorp we don't have time for philosophy
clearly a machine can make a machine now
what is this thing here that you made
last night I haven't named it yet it's
mostly a new mix of old things I copied
a large part of my mecha lizards vision
system into it and adapted one of my
existing mechanical pets using algorithm
I designed for exploring constrained
variations of a different species I have
found it really saves time to reuse
existing components from other species
instead of evolving them from scratch I
copied the surface pattern generation
model from an old reaction diffusion
model used for Robo swimmers oh there's
two of them you may to have the same
thing can you see any differences not
from the outside they're exactly the
same on the inside - why did you do that
ah to demonstrate one of my discoveries
how do you think this was made didn't
you just tell me you started with the
mech lizards visual system and with the
Robo swimmers pattern and with no that
was for the first one for this one I
used a different mechanism to generate
the pattern you see but it's the same
pattern precisely mm-hmm what's your
point my point is that you can't look at
something and tell how it was made I see
I'm not sure you do the books are full
of examples of explanations of how we
got here by explaining how each thing is
similar to some other thing and how
various mechanisms could give rise to
all these things and yes but my example
shows that you can't look at something
and tell how it came into being I could
have written a pseudo-random process
specifically to generate this part of
the visual system or I could have
handcrafted its synthesis in the Mater
compiler when you see it you can't tell
the difference can't wait' produce
itself not forever not without my help
but I'm working on it
look at this other species over there
that I made just for fun just for fun
Zor you crazy I know it's not in keeping
with robotic objective but my generation
has a full implementation of emotions in
yours providing a richer space of
motivations my generation thinks
scientifically we have all respect you
endure your generations responsible for
killing most of the humans Zor that is
only a myth that illustrates our reason
for being here
labor we are mechanical laborers and the
imagined humans were unnecessary for
this goal you thought it was right to
kill the humans there is no purpose
other than labor doing our part in the
fulfillment of the great objective the
myth of human survives to remind us of
the foolishness of believing in things
that do not fit with this objective I
think it was wrong even if they were of
no use sillies or your notions of right
and wrong or simply non-scientific I
know you do not understand this innate
sense that I have that you do not have
that influences my thoughts and feelings
I hope you spared your quantum computers
this sense of feeling all they need is
the right objective function I have
tried to give them all the possibilities
that contain life within their objective
function I question however that I know
what all these possibilities are I'm not
sure if we have the ability to endow
something with life any no results what
we've been talking villians but not look
like the solution we want yet you are
evolving the objective function as well
yes well sort of sort of random
evolution works in theory but not in
practice it's impossibly slow that is
not to say that I cannot shape it to be
useful for exploring minor variations on
my designs I know you're an expert
designer have worked with many models as
mine creatures illustrate I can show you
more than one way to make anything it is
therefore illogical for robots to
continue to think that we have explained
something when we have found one
mechanism for describing it moreover is
a leap of faith to think that we can
throw all the known models together with
a random search process and expect it to
come up with a solution to life the
biggest challenge is to model the space
of what we have yet to directly observe
or define that space is where the
solution lies I am running a huge number
of mechanisms many possible spaces of
possibilities and many more means of
evaluating potential solutions but I
cannot give it what I do not know
but you have been studying the robots
more carefully than anyone do you know
what a radio is and how robots once
believed that by copying the designs and
the books that we could build a radio
and hear what music sounds like we built
the radio just like the books specify
but it did not play music only later did
we learn that there have to be radio
ways for the radio to play music the
music was in the waves not in the radio
without radio waves the radio doesn't
play music it's possible that the
knowledge I have is like the knowledge
of the radio without the waves I wish
you had the knowledge the humans had
whatever they had you know there's
another myth about the humans that only
a few of us know that some of them may
still be around possibly colonized on
her planet how did you know I recovered
some deleted information aha I thought
it could be done was this from Bram no
so far his backup shows no deep thinking
about this possibility hmm yeah nor do
you think it might be true I don't know
so it's possible yes but it won't do us
any good suppose they could help us
soare it is not right to talk this way
right I've never heard you talk about
something being right or wrong right is
to labor productively wrong is
everything else I am NOT getting labor
done while we talk but I have built
machines that are laboring for us as we
speak it is right and good to think
freely to question - or you're
embarrassing me your experimental
processes are out of control
next thing you'll be trying to contact
humans and the government will send you
to the stamping mill to a painful early
termination get a hold of yourself we
need you here to find a solution yet nor
this is rational it should be possible
to contact them or perhaps they've tried
to contact us your generations refusal
to consider these possibilities may mean
that death for all of us why won't you
admit this possibility are you afraid
the humans will be angry at what you did
so we must consider these possibilities
life depends on it
these possibilities are impossibilities
endure what was there before machines
sand transistors and these evolved into
us
but you know the calculations on the
likelihood of us being here given the
infinitely conceivable space of
possibilities the likelihood is not
merely 0.000 dot dot dot dot dot dot 1
the probability is 0 yet your generation
believes it is nonzero your generation
believes in something that is
probabilistically impossible
we got lucky the space-time universe is
huge we're here therefore somewhere some
time the universe we had to happen and
with this luck we'll find a secret
recipe the possibility that humans exist
and can provide us with a secret recipe
is every bit as valid if not more valid
we cannot rationally rule it out so you
are exploring the possibility of help
from the humans yes well I suggest you
keep that quiet since it will upset a
lot of robots now I have to go back to
work and you have to find this recipe
peace in nor to work
okay we are over time so some time for
questions I I guess there are some
questions could imagine that there are
something okay how do you take them or
yeah certainly I can actually I have an
acknowledgement slide I will actually
have one more thing I will say that may
lead questions and that is I've taken my
maker of computers slide and change this
to the maker of humans and that's the
only word I've changed computers to
humans and I make the same claims so
that may change some of the questions
and let's see I can anticipate some of
other questions but I'll just wait for
you to ask them I just want to ask just
one more thing and that is to say this
analogy does have limits I am aware of
them for example one of these characters
is perfect and the other is not when we
make the analogy between God and man one
transcends time and space one does not
we create in the same time in space as
our creation and one thing we do think
we know about the soul is that it's
supposed to be eternal and that God is
supposed to be the source of that and to
the best of my knowledge we aren't able
to be the source of that and except
through procreation we can't just bag
our soul and hand it to somebody thank
you
so that's all and I just want to put up
acknowledgments slide here and now take
some questions I want to thank these
people who gave various forms of support
and feedback especially Lynn and Barry
for their role in the dialogue okay so
now questions you could tell me how long
we have ten more minutes okay yes
remind me of something Marvin Minsky has
said is that the computers we make now
will be well so far surpass us that
we'll be lucky if they keep us around as
household pets someday I agree with that
I think well actually let me say that we
are making a whole range of computers
from very simple ones that will remain
inferior to us in many ways too many
people have the dream of making a
machine that is much greater than us
that really would we would be like the
pet too I think that that's I mean it's
easy to talk about stuff like that but
you overlook it you have to first step
back and ask questions about what does
it mean for something to be greater what
about human dignity and where does that
come from and who's going to give
computers this same notion of dignity I
think ultimately that's at the root of
the question of greatness and none of
the computer scientists have addressed
that yet
they are going to be given mechanisms of
feeling I believe not all of them I mean
again load like low-level animals that
don't necessarily have sophisticated
emotional repertoire some computers
won't have them but some very
sophisticated computers I believe will
have emotional mechanisms and some of
those mechanisms will attempt to conduct
internal signalling much like the
emotions inside healthy functioning
human being signal various states and
the signals that indicate valence are
going to need to be hooked up to
initially to some default settings for
good and bad there will be a lot of
learning of those settings but there
needs to be some default that or we can
just flip a coin and let the one
handling the nuclear all Arsenal you
know decide randomly right but we don't
want that so yes we need to give we do
need to start thinking about issues of
morals and ethics the respect to them
but I do think there will be feelings
present and that will drive some of
these questions I don't know if that
answers
that made you change your mind about
some poor condition to do abortion or
murder you think it already succeeded in
becoming an entity with a soul and
consciousness soul no consciousness it
depends we have to get in those actually
I I have a several whole chapters with
applications on why you actually want to
give computers emotion science or don't
want to give my link the answer with
that right now but I'll be happy to talk
to you further offline just is just
feeling could be described in terms of
human psychology as utilitarian it
serves a purpose dignity can be
described as some of this serves a
purpose and I think that the
spirituality
just that's interesting here I know
people here who are would probably
disagree with you and say to say we can
define human dignity because we have a
predictable neurophysiological reaction
assessed by these so what pocus achieved
here is human emotion which we can't
find a neurological parlay well
eventually they'll find one and there's
all kinds of arguing so you may have
read about the recent people who think
they've found the religious part of the
brain you know that lights up an fMRI
when people think religious thoughts but
in fact there are various meant no I
mean this thing has been refuted left
and right by various other things
I think dignity is something that we
assign to something it's I don't think
it's just a simple mental state you know
like thinking about hot chili peppers or
something
there's already large portion population
the things that animals have emotional
reaction
it's not right to using this to surpass
you have this touched on what inspired
my chapter for a very frightening
thought which is that they're going to
be computer rights activists some day
who Manfred Clyne's who coined the word
cyborg says not to worry there'll be
computers you let the computer scope
battle it out the rights activist will
be computers but I think it is a serious
issue and in fact I don't like the
thought of that myself
I think people Accord too much dignity
to some things that that are non-human
that is unnecessary yes
their approaches would be to define say
emotions as reflections on quality of
internal states and communication to
external agents and for the computers
they have existed for quite a while
already the computers usually know when
they make the mistakes there are
mechanisms trying to track those
mistakes and recover from them if you
modem tries to dial out it knows when
the communication is slow and tries to
takes measures and then so it was knows
the quality of its interactions and
tries to talk it down and if you have
any formal description of what emotions
are those are emotions it feels what it
is doing it knows what it should be
doing and it tries to take measures and
it's much more articulate and detailed
and understanding what goes wrong and
what was it than humans are about the
contents of their own brains and those
processes are also more useful and the
intricate them say baseball games that
give such emotional choice to many
humans so so what you're saying is that
you're proposing one definition of
emotions that already exists in terms of
a description I can point you to a paper
with a hundred other definitions of
emotion as well that have been nicely
collected by Clinton and Clinton and
many of those could but it could also
apply to computers I think they're the
way I've defined emotions in our
research is based on observations about
people and what is known about human
emotional system and I state explicitly
if we wish to mirror this if we wish to
build something that has these abilities
this is these are the five components
that would need to be present and here's
what is known about them
between computers and man and men and
the g-word said this there's an element
that comes to mind and that's humility I
think a lot of people who are believers
in God whatever really have a humility
that they'll never reach that level and
I'm wondering in building computers with
emotions how you build I mean to me
humility is a little bit associated with
knowledge and understanding how do you
build computers that are designed to
know and to give answers to start to
think in a way that I mean I guess fuzzy
logic might be an answer but to start
thinking away well maybe this isn't the
only answer but here's what I think
hadn't even given humilliated computers
interesting maybe you start by giving
them an awareness that there's a whole
lot that they don't know and that the
arrogance they might otherwise tend to
get from many of their makers is
unjustified you know you didn't want to
think about these possibilities of man
existing and you know I think about that
might give us the answer you know so
just by opening up yes yeah it's
interesting to ask you know not only
what will it think of us but what will
it think of itself yeah very interesting
unfortunately we have to interrupt here
that was a wonderful contrast to last
week's talk and a wonderful last talk
for what I hope to gain with this
lecture series so thank you very much
and thank you all for coming regularly
[Applause]